thanks for uh Ali Reza back-to-back
victories before this round but today
you are on the ropes defending with
black pieces early on against Fabia
player that you don't have a very good
uh result against in general how did you
approach this matchup what was the
strategy going into today's round yeah
um for sure been fabi's on form it's
very difficult to play against him
he has crazy results when he's on forms
and and today he really played amazing
chess and I was under the pressure under
pressure the whole game so and I was
kind of very lucky to Escape withdrawal
today and yeah the opening was
I think he made a very good opening
choice but I I knew this line from
before and up to C5 yeah yeah before
yeah I think I don't remember exactly
but I think these are all correct
and
um it's not an easy position yeah right
I think I am there is bit more correct
way probably instead of here but it
should be okay
um yeah but white is it white has the
edge here so it's not easy and
he put a lot of pressure here and 95 is
an interesting move yeah here probably
after Queen D5 is probably a mistake and
yeah there's F6 Queen D6 should be equal
I'm I was a bit too optimistic here and
I played this 25 and he played this
amazing group so what are the risks that
you're taking and in this position my
knight on A5 is terrible and it's always
out of the game and my king could be
weak with Knight G4 always and horn on
F7 if I move the Rook it the whole
problem is Knight on A5 and Pawn on B7
and his pieces are very good well
managed here and I don't have a good
place for my queen so I had to solve all
of this but it was not possible and his
King is a bit safer as well right yeah
but I think I could have solved it
tactically here
okay it is good move
93 no you're you're defending very well
at this point and here I said I am
probably lost
really that's how you assessed it yeah
because it's very inactive for my pieces
but I I always have chance but was it
also because of the time situation yeah
and all the time situation but I thought
it's very hopeless my position
especially
here after 93 is a great move
I couldn't find anything better because
I couldn't assist it after for instance
King F7 95
uh
if I give up the phone I said I'm lost
so what waited Knight C5 yeah it takes
Rook B7 he could keep the pawn somehow
and I said this is very hopeless
computer of course defense somehow and
obviously for Knight C3 yeah yeah it's
very hopeless I think this position
practically at least computer maybe
could defend but practical is I said
Isis is my only chance but of course it
should be Loosely The Rook on C7 but
yeah
he played he was also getting in time
trouble here and he couldn't find the
best line but I'm sure Jeep he has to
play for maid here E4 H4 for everything
maybe like Knight H6 getting to h8 and
then push the pawns basically you can
bring the king to C4
and he has all the time in the world it
seems like right yeah he was he wanted
to finish the game quickly I think so
you guys actually got to move like 41.
yeah yeah and that's where the big
mistake came with this move Knight to C4
he was out of danger in terms of his
time situation right yeah he got the 40
moves
actually he played 94 and he put it back
so oh so he did play it and he realized
that in the exact moment yeah it was a
cold shower
yeah yeah of course I think if he plays
Rook season I will lose the game slowly
slowly
[Music]
is big
it was just luck here that he missed
Knight C4 when he got time 30 minutes
yeah yeah
um well luck is definitely necessary in
chess occasionally right
um still a great result for you with
black pieces you still have a couple of
whites left was the strategy was the
plan for the last three rounds the
championship rounds yeah always in every
tournament the last two rounds are the
most important and he's a decider so I'm
happy I have two whites
and I will try to play good chess I
cannot change anything and I have to try
my best and we will see what happens one
more question actually because we had
another very weird instance it was this
game between dingley Rand and Wesley
first of all ding went completely
Out For Blood yeah with like Knight F4
E4 F3 just trying to push his pieces in
the center
game but it seemed like he was
completely winning at one point and I
want to ask you about the last
moment of the game where Wesley was in
fact winning but he decided to repeat
did you look did you see this position
in the clay
you were focused on your game yeah I had
a lot of problems
focus on other games but yeah it's weird
and he decides a lot of uh intriguing
things are happening today in today's
round is it the energy levels is it like
uh the day after the rest day yeah this
is typical Wesley he wins one game in
the tournament and makes drawn but this
is weird this he has to drive
thank you for uh joining us we'll see
you in the next rounds and we're going
to take a short commercial break and
we'll be back with the final moments of
the last game the one between Max
investor on the graph and Richie report
we'll be back shortly don't go anywhere
[Music]